[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them
[Music]
foreign
and with a hand gesture told
to go [__] himself and that is exactly
the feeling that a rest of America feels
when they see Donald Trump looking
through
a private box waving at the folks down
below isn't that kind of funny the
imagery of it of it all and because
Rhonda Santos was there as well at the
Iowa Iowa State game I'm talking about
uh where Trump was booed and flipped off
told him to go [__] himself also Miranda
Santos was flipped off too they were
flipping him off too even in Iowa now to
be fair there is a large portion of Iowa
that are liberal they're very blue Iowa
tends to have larger swaths of rural
areas that have a blue tinge to them in
other words they believe in Liberty and
freedom and not oppressing people
not burning books or or getting rid of
Education or you know none of that stuff
actual they don't actually the the blue
Democrats in Iowa actually don't want to
do grooming like the Republicans do like
Kim Reynolds the governor of Iowa
wouldn't want to do but here's the thing
is Rhonda Santos you know the Donald
Trump we'll get to the Donald Trump part
right we're gonna get that I want to I
want to handle Ron DeSantis because it's
really simple it's really easy Ronda
Santos went to the eye while I was
taking because he knew Trump was going
to be there and he knew Trump was going
to be in the private box so what he
thought was is look here's the thing
here's the thing
is I'll be down in the stands with the
people and not only that he's he's like
I guess he made some suggestion that Kim
Reynolds might be in the running for
vice president his vice president or
something
Ron you're not going to be president
dude you're not going to have to pick a
vice president number one and number two
Iowa Iowans don't like you
they don't like you no matter if you
would even suggest that Kim Reynolds
would be
the vice president they still don't they
still don't like you they don't like
Donald Trump either
there was an audible boo when he came
out to wave to what he thought was Micah
in Iowa what he didn't understand is not
only Maca is allowed to buy tickets at a
football game in Iowa
the best part about the booing part when
he walks out is Right Wingers on the
internet change the audio
so it didn't appear that he was booed as
much which is [__] fantastic
oh my god listen if Maga is out there
changing the audio on a tape of Donald
Trump getting booed
because they can't handle that he's
unpopular
I mean that's just a good sign folks
that's a hell of a good sign that they
have to Gaslight their own supporters
because that's what it is they're not
trying to convince us
you know people who can use you know the
what brain cells we have left to realize
that you're [__] foolish [__] when
you change the audio on a video so it
doesn't sound like Trump's boot as much
right
but here's the thing is they're trying
to convince their sheep that he's still
popular when he's not
because really that's the [__] story
that's the [__] story there of the
Iowa Iowa State game it's nor Rhonda
Santa's fascist says from Florida or
Trump is not popular at all are not as
popular as they would want to make
people think they are because that's
truly the big lie you know everyone
talks about the big lie
let Trump won he didn't lose and he's
not going to concede I won it was it was
it was rigged against me you know he
says that kind of [__] that's the big
that's not the big line the biggest lie
that has ever been told to America and I
believe the biggest lie that
large parts of America whether you like
him or hate him
believe is that somehow he has this big
huge resounding popularity in this
country which is all a bunch of [__]
most people don't like that [__]
and the P A lot of people don't like him
and aren't willing to even say it out
loud they just secretly don't like him
and the reason why is because they lives
in they live in parts of the country or
they work in parts of the country or
they have groups of people around them
who are who are [__] cult members so
they don't want to shake things up you
know what I mean
they get in a group of people and they
would rather just affiliate with them
and maybe sometimes that leads them to
vote for that scumbag because of that
affiliation right because we I've told
you the reason why they still people
still vote for Republicans is two
reasons Republican lies they believe
them and affiliation they don't
necessarily believe the lies what they
want to right they're not full-on
members of The Cult they just know
people who are
and the cult doesn't seem so bad outside
[Laughter]
my God oh my God it is 9 11 as well we
were talking in the uh today was the
first pre-show that we did I called it
what did I call it I called it the the
[__] em the [__] them early morning
that's what I called it the producer
Corner over on Discord
um if you want to get joined in on the
pre-show on Mondays and Fridays we did
our first one today and we talked about
9 11 there we talked about smoking weed
we talked about Trump getting flipped
off at the Iowa game we talked about
project 2025 in there which is the funny
story about that
um but it was a great time and a great
time with you guys uh in the producers
Corner this morning or the [__] them
early morning we'll figure out what
we're going to call that thing and we'll
nail that to the ground eventually and
we'll figure out what it is so if you
want to join if you're on the patreon on
the 20 tier or more you can join in on
Discord over there just go join the
Discord server again go to the
tonymichaels.com scroll down you'll see
the Discord server there join in verify
and get yourself very verified uh for
patreon to be in the early morning show
on Mondays and Fridays I know it'll take
a few weeks for you guys to get used to
that I'll be in there but you'll get
used to the schedule and we'll we'll be
um in the same place at once so don't
get frustrated if you missed it this
morning there will be plenty of them
we're going to do them every Monday and
Friday so they'll be there every week
for us to start the week and end the
week and together also changes this week
will be that Gabe Sanchez he'll be
joining us today as a co-host but
Tuesday Wednesday Thursday he'll be
doing his own hour what was that live
after for this show on YouTube and
twitch so if you're on YouTube and
twitch you'll automatically go to his
show if you're on Facebook you got to go
to YouTube or twitch to go from my show
to Gabe's show
uh but anyways oh we were talking about
9 11. that's right because today is is
today is Monday September 11th
it's been 22 years since the towers fall
in New York and the Pentagon was hit and
the people
um
shaped Wise by taking down the plane in
Pennsylvania and
um you know there's going to be a lot of
stuff on TV a lot of uh stuff that
triggers folks I'm gonna show a video
today so if you're sensitive to some of
that September 11th stuff I'll I'll warn
you before I'm gonna play it but I think
it's worth playing it was a a video that
I think 50 Shades away posted on Twitter
it shows some of those more memorable
Infamous
um very disastrous moments
um
that shook our country and shook our
world into this Post 9 11 situation you
know and thinking about 9 11 and the
lead story where Iowa gives Trump the
middle finger I think about I think
about Trump in the context of domestic
terrorism
you know what I mean and I think about
what it means on 9 11 that September
11th happened because as I told the
people in the chat this morning
you know maybe maybe you don't think
this
but a lot of the reasons why Al-Qaeda
flew those planes into buildings is
because of our way of life and our
culture here in this country
they were losing the culture wars
against us folks
a lot of them a lot of culture wars they
were losing against this their their
fascist conservative religious ways
um you know owning women as property
making sure certain people don't have
rights like the lgbtq community women
Outsiders of their of their culture
don't have rights and they don't they
didn't like our culture they didn't like
our culture they didn't like I mean they
bombed the the Twin Towers
just a decade before you know people
forget that sometimes money librarian
brought that up in the uh
in the pre-show chant this morning
we forget those things right and we
forget why why it happened
we forget why
and a lot of times folks want to say
it's old because we are world power and
they were trying to bring us to our
knees well what did they care if we were
a world power
what was it about us being a world power
that's so infuriated them what was it
was it our culture was it our culture to
to have an Empire and
and go to a region and win a war and
then leave them stranded
or or was it was it that we like sex
drugs and rock and roll
essentially I mean there's more to it
than that but you know
I guess one way of describing it
what was it what was it that led them to
hate our culture to want to bring us to
our knees
and it reminds me it reminds me of why
people went
to the Capitol on 9 11. right wise
deceit delusion
they were they were
they were led to believe things that
just were not true that were going on
right in front of their face
I mean is America perfect no
it's not perfect it never has been I
mean that's kind of the point
is that we're not perfect is that we
strive to be a more
a more perfect union but we're not
perfect that's the whole point is to
progress towards better equality and
Equity a better way of life for everyone
who's here whether you're a citizen or
non-citizen or a refugee
whether you were born here or came here
as a child
or immigrated here as an adult
this is supposed to be the land of
liberty and freedom
right
and that in that why
they felt the need to attack us on 9 11.
and not just and not just attack our
government military
think about it for a second think about
where those planes flew where they
landed what their targets were
I mean there was really only two planes
half the planes were only designated
for the the central power of the federal
government
in the United States
and only one of them was towards a
quote-unquote military Target
in the Pentagon
think about that for a second
what what does the World Trade Center
have anything to do
with attacking our military it doesn't
it has to do with attacking our culture
our way of life here in America
the idea of Liberty and freedom
and using freedoms and rights to deliver
that Liberty
and they want it to strike at the heart
of it is what they wanted
so
why why then
why then
do you ask
is Enrique itario and Stuart Rhodes now
sitting in a prison for domestic
terrorism
what was it what was it that they were
so upset
do they love Donald Trump so much
do they they love Donald Trump so much
that they were willing to commit
terrorist acts domestic terrorist acts
to try to overthrow and topple our our
way of life
that's truly what they were doing on
January 6 folks
there's no question
they were attacking our constitution
they were attacking our Liberty they
were attacking our freedoms to vote for
who we want to vote to decide as a
nation
through our democracy of what our
constitutional republic will look like
and who will be in charge of our
Republic
that's the whole point
and they got really upset that they
didn't get their way
so much so that they were willing to
commit acts of violence and domestic
terrorist terrorism
to topple our government that we chose
We the People chose that government
we made those choices on that day in
November
of 2020. and when they came on January 6
to terrorize our nation
into not believing that we did that
thing
and to just say you know what you're
right you're you know we would much
rather be peaceful and not have violence
and we'll just give you the government
is that what they thought they were
going to do
that's what Al Qaeda thought they were
going to do on September 11th that they
would crash our system
that they would send us in such a
tailspin
that we wouldn't be able to fight back
and we did we did fight back
we fought really stupid dumb unrelated
Wars in an effort to fight back to send
a message
and looking back on it now
seems even more ridiculous
than when it did in 2002 and 2003
but it is ridiculous
but did did the Terrorist on 9 11
did they think we wouldn't fight back
and the more the question really is do
the domestic terrorists in our country
right now the Insurgency in our country
right now
do they believe that we won't fight for
our country
do they believe that we won't band
together as a pro-democracy coalition
and use the power of our ballot
to advance our democracy
do they really believe that
I have a hard time thinking
that they don't I think they think we
will cower
I think they believe this idea that
liberals small L liberals people who
believe in Liberal democracy no matter
if you disagree on this issue or that
issue or you're trying to figure out
what wages the exact amount wages should
be or the exact amount of Health Care
that a person should get
what the government's role is in this
thing or that thing
you know we those are all things we can
argue
but can can we stand here and say that
is that Trump is so popular
that we're going to stand here and not
argue that democracy should carry on
they truly believe that they believe
that their authoritarian ways are going
to somehow
Crush democracy
I don't believe that
I don't believe that that's the case
I believe that we as the liberal
Coalition the pro-democracy small L
liberal don't get confused
you can go look up the words liberal and
fascist
and know the difference
now I was talking to a good friend of
mine this morning
and he we were talking about and he's a
he's a not a republican but he votes
Republican
and we're talking this morning about
these differences
and this just happens that it was on 9
11 this morning that we were talking
about these differences and we're
talking about who's the fascist party in
this country and who isn't
and I believe sometimes the confusion
the confusion of what our system of
government truly is
is sometimes the way that people's
deluded Minds get in a situation where
they believe that we are not the
government
it's a it's a democratic constitutional
republic
we the people vote for who goes and
represents Us in the government
and we can fire them
when it comes around to re-election
we can do that inside of our democracy
and not only can we fire them once we
fire them we can tell them you need not
apply
just like Donald Trump is trying to
reapply for for us to put him in power
to give him the job of being the
president which he was no good at
anyways he wasn't even good at
pretending to be the president if you
want to be quite honest
and that is the confusion
of who is fascist
in this country and we must remember
these ideas and we must talk about them
we can't ignore these things these are
very simple things to understand
we are the government it is us the
people it is the ballot
in which is decided who controls our
democracy
and we
control that ballot It Is Us
and we must we must stay vigilant
again this is the most important
election of our lifetime the one that's
coming
just like the last one 2022 was the most
important of our democracy's lifetime in
2020 before that
and I would imagine that that 2026 and
2028 will be just as important
I don't see fascism hiding underneath
this rock anytime soon it's going to
take a long time to get them to hide
away they're so comfortable being right
out in the open and the reason why is
because a lot of Americans are confused
about what fascism is
and what liberalism is it's what led
those terrorists to get on planes and
fly them into the Twin Towers it's the
same principle it's the same delusion
it's the same confusion
now you can call it an opinion but it's
not an opinion opinions are based in
fact
you have to agree on a certain set of
effects to form an opinion
a belief can be based on facts but it
doesn't have to be
it can be based on any kind of delusion
that your mind can make
and form
and the delusion in this country
that we do not have a democracy and we
do not have a say is just that
and when we start to disengage
because we are discouraged
that is when we will lose our democracy
because folks there is a there is a
hefty percentage of people in this
country who do not believe we have a
democracy they have been fundamentally
brainwashed into believing that a
republic our Republic is not a democracy
and we do not have a say and that is
just fundamentally wrong
we do have a say
we do have the power of the majority
they work hard they work hard to control
large swaths of our country with the
minority and they've done a pretty damn
good job of it in some places
but that that must not stop us that must
not discourage us because the minute we
get to discourage we will disengage
think of 9 11.
on today September 11th think of 9 11.
when they attacked us
they didn't just attack you or me
they didn't just
kill thousands of people in New York
City
they attacked the heart
of our soul and our culture as a nation
that was their goal
that was their intent
now it was outside forces that did this
so we all looked at each other and band
together
and became Americans regardless if we
were born here or what religion we
practiced
what state we're from whether we were
from a city or from a rural area
in that moment
we looked at each other and said you
know what [__] it we're all Americans
this is different though
this Insurgency
from inside is way different
it's way different
and we must ban a coalition just like we
did on 9 11 when we all got together no
matter who we voted for no matter what
religion we were what thought process we
we had
and we looked at each other and said we
should not we should not tolerate
someone attacking our country and our
culture and our society
and our way of life like they've done
because they don't believe
in what we believe
that's what the Insurgency in this
country is doing they're attacking us at
all at all places not just physically
like on January 6th
are like the lone attackers the one in
the Dollar General the guy out in Utah
that got killed by the FBI the one that
showed up with the nail gun and I think
it was Cincinnati at an FBI headquarters
and every other the person that showed
up with a hammer at Nancy Pelosi's house
he's crazy chewing on manga lunatics
this Insurgency
is real and it can be violent
but we must fight on the battlefield
that is to be fought and that is the
ballot and that is misinformation
and the way we do that the way we do
that is we stay vigilant
against anyone and everyone I don't care
what Coalition they say they're in I
don't care what they say they're for or
against attacking
attacking our
institutions of democracy
and even skewing the ideas of our
institutions of democracy it is
important to remember that today
as we laugh and mock Donald Trump for
being so unpopular that he was booed and
flipped off in Iowa you're like Tony
what the hell does that have to do with
9 11 domestic terrorists it has
everything to do with it
they are trying to convince our country
that he is popular and he is not
just like when when they committed
attacks of terrorism on our country
in the 90s
and on that day of 9 11 they were trying
to convince our country that we were
weak
and that we would fall
and that we weren't the most powerful
country in the world
and who knows if we truly are I mean do
we really want to test that or should we
test that
but I know one thing
I know one thing that the majority of
people in this country believe in
democracy
the majority of the people in this
country believe in one another as a
collective not just as individuals
because that's what we became on that
day and that's what I think the good of
Post 9 11 America is is that we are a
collective
we are in this together we've seen it
during the pandemic yes we had outliers
of course we did
the Insurgency was you know rooted by
the time the pandemic rolled around
but we are a collective we are a
collective of individuals in this
country and we as the pro-democracy
Coalition can collectively save our
nation
from The Surge of fascism real fascism
not fake ass all the government this and
the government that we are the
government the government is us
by our decisions by our engagement by us
using the ballot we become the
government it is us and I want you to
remember that
on this day September 11th when you're
remembering 9 11 and what happened that
day what happened during the pandemic
and what led up to
January 6. even even during the 2008
financial crisis
now we discovered a lot about of our
nation then we've discovered so much
about of our nation in the last 30 years
and we need not forget those things we
need to have those things at our
disposal to know the truth
and the truth
the truth is I'm glad to have you here
again every single weekday Monday
through Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9
Pacific
on YouTube don't forget to subscribe on
YouTube You're Gonna Wanna subscribe on
YouTube you're also going to want to
follow us on Twitch because those two
places on Tuesdays Wednesdays and
Thursdays are going to be the place
where we go straight to Gabe Sanchez
after this two-hour show we're gonna go
to Gabe singers what was that live I got
a great announcement tomorrow we had a
great guest Greg o'lear is going to be
on the show and Texas Paul is going to
be here tomorrow too so we got Greg
o'lear on the show I was on I actually
recorded for his podcast on Sunday
yesterday and I think it's going to air
on Friday so he's going to come talk to
us tomorrow here on the Tony Michaels
podcast I'm super excited about that go
to the Tony michaels.com that's the Tony
michaels.com subscribe at the top of the
website there check out all the Links
come visit us on patreon and visit us in
the Discord and make sure that you get
in on the producers Corner that we had
this morning had a lot of fun again
thank you very much for everyone for
being there don't go anywhere we'll be
right back right after this
[Music]
we'll be right back Mark
seconds
Tony Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard and blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardons not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
holy moly we got a birthday in the chat
long time listener good friend of mine
hi Ross
happy birthday to you
happy birthday to you everyone wished I
a happy birthday in the chat so glad to
have ty not only as a listener here but
as a great friend Ty actually helps I'm
gonna outer here she actually helps
write some of the descriptions
um that you see on YouTube
um so and and the title she inspires the
title a lot and the thumbnails with her
brilliant uh just
sharp as a whip
she gets it right there with her writing
so thank you Ty and happy birthday Ty so
everyone wished Ty a happy birthday also
I want to thank everyone uh last night
on the patreon Sunday rant you guys join
me we didn't rant a lot last night I
know someone mentioned that it was a lot
of self-promotion last night but I was
trying to lay out the schedule for what
was going to happen this week I wanted
everyone to get a good idea that this
week is going to be a little different
it's just going to be a little different
the good news is there's going to be
more content for you guys because Gabe
Sanchez is going to do a full hour after
this show on Tuesdays Wednesdays and
Thursdays from now on I'll be doing a
pre-patreon only show so if you want to
check that out go to patreon.com
or just go to thetonymichaels.com hit
the patreon button there but also you're
going to want to follow the Discord we
did it in Discord this morning it worked
really well it's almost like a a Twitter
spaces but our own little private one so
if you want to join in on that show
it'll be Mondays and Fridays before the
show we'll be talking about topics as I
set up the show now they were really
worried this morning that I was I would
you know get distracted but we did great
we did great we talked I got the show
ready everything's good it worked
perfect it worked just as I hoped it
would and it worked turned out great but
yesterday
um last night on the Sunday rant a lot
of people bought me shots so I want to
give shout outs there Tracy's Cynthia we
had Megan Derek oddly wired and Melissa
bought shots either last night or this
morning so I really appreciate all the
support and some of that will definitely
go to alcohol but I we run off your
support here on the show you know that I
can't
I can't attract corporate sponsors one
reason why is because they don't like my
mouth but uh you know what I wouldn't
want them to tell me what the hell I
could and couldn't say anyways um so we
run off your support the audience
support So if you want if you want to
show support you can go to the Tony
michaels.com you can buy me a shot or
put some um something in the tip jar you
can also go and do a venmo super chat
there on the Tony michaels.com just hit
the link there it'll take you to the
venmo account make sure if you send me a
message on venmo because I'll bring it
up on the screen here make sure you put
your handle on what platform you're on
so I can give you a shout out there of
what your handle is
on that platform again go to the Tony
michaels.com all those links are there
and don't forget to subscribe there as
well I really appreciate all your guys's
support I know that you also are
supporting Gabe Sanchez in his effort to
have this show on his own channel
it's fantastic oh people reminded me to
hit the like button
and share the show with others make sure
to hit the like button and share and
subscribe it's free to subscribe here on
YouTube or if you're on Twitch follow if
you're on Facebook follow me there too
I've had a lot of questions here lately
should I sort this out now I don't know
if I should sort this out now or not
yeah a lot of people and they won't stop
asking they won't stop asking
about about Facebook
they won't stop
so I I might as well because it's not as
salacious as you think
I wish I wish there I wish it was I wish
I had a great story to tell you and it
was some kind of crazy thing
but it's not I I have been a Midas Touch
contributor for some time now for I
think over a year now I've been a minus
touch contributor where we contribute to
mindsets you guys know
um that we did a lot of interviews for
them we did um one of the first
interviews that they aired for us that
we put on their Channel as a contributor
was the interview with
um Tasha Adams and Dakota Dakota Adams
that Stuart Rhodes's ex-wife and his
estranged son that was one of the first
interviews that we actually was a
contributor
but we were never officially one of
their shows officially
um we were just a contributor as a show
and using this content as in that way
um we we broadcast to their Facebook
page I never broadcasted to their
YouTube page we always broadcast it to
their Facebook page because they felt
like it was a good space for me and I
felt like it was too I felt like it was
too and we got a lot out of it we got a
lot out of our partnership I love the
mizellis brothers Ben Jordi and Brett
they they've done a lot for our show and
they're great guys they do great work
they produce a lot of material
and I was a contributor for a long time
still am Gabe Sanchez as a contributor
as well to the minus touch Network he
puts a lot of the what was that over
there on the Midas touch Network he also
does some shorts too
we used to have bonehead of the week
over there but it didn't fit their
Channel as well as it used to which you
know we recognized when the content
doesn't necessarily fit the fit the
channel exactly and we agreed on that we
changed it we we didn't do the whole
episode we did the we paired it down a
bit and it just it just never played
like we wanted it to play
over there
so there's not we have no beef with
minus touch and the reason why the main
reason why I took
um my show off the minus touch Facebook
page which that was my decision not
theirs
the reason why it has nothing to do with
a beef we have no beef
at all
we are we I'm I'm I still could be a
contributor if I wanted to be
but I felt like for the independence of
the show
and for the audience it would be best if
we did it on my own page and I worked
long and hard to broadcast from Facebook
because I'm not a fan
I'm not a fan of Facebook as you well
know Gabe Sanchez won't even go on
Facebook
um so I I did I think for a while to get
everyone over to my Facebook page and I
stream from my Facebook page so for all
of you out there wondering if there's
some kind of split there was no split
there was no split
um we we just and I did the January 6
select hearings for them which is a
great step for the mind is touch Network
by the way that was a huge step for them
um me and Gabe were gonna stream that
thing if you want to know the story
behind the January six select hearings
me and Gabe were gonna we're we're going
to stream that thing because I think you
guys had recommended in the chat one day
when we were talking about it live on
the show like it it became a thing live
on the show and we thought it was such a
great idea me and Gabe thought it was
such a great idea that we would see if
the my jealous Brothers wanted to do it
on the minus touch Network and it took a
little bit of convincing not much but a
little bit and they agreed
and it was so successful
it was so successful and I got to do a
lot of great things during those January
6 hearings I got to interview Ron Reagan
um Michael Cohen was there Jessica
Denson was there we had poke we had KFA
Rachel bidikoffer joined us David Bender
joined us several times Michael Cohen
did I already say Michael going a
politics girl Lee McGowan joined us and
there were so many other personalities
that contributed to that January 6
select hearings and we learned we
learned so much by doing those hearings
um but my passion is live broadcasting
it truly is live broadcasting and I want
to do a live show every single day
for for several different reasons
but the two hour format the three hour
format are the long format of an entire
radio show doesn't exactly fit
and it's okay that's okay that that
doesn't change that the Midas Mighty are
welcome here that doesn't mean that I'm
not welcome over on the Midas touch
Network
that does I'm still a technically a
contributor if if I wanted to to be I
guess I could probably say hey do you
want some content and they would love
that
but I want to concentrate on this show I
believe in this show and this show is so
important to you guys is what makes it
important to me
so there's no beef there was no split
and I know everyone's been talking
because people tag me on Facebook the
other thing I see too is like Tony
doesn't read Facebook comments I read
them
some of them but I can't read all of
[Laughter]
I I can't read all of them
they're so fast and there's so many
so if you think that I'm ignoring you
it's not because I'm ignoring you it's
because I just don't see that comment or
your comment and I don't I don't respond
to every single comment because I would
so I would be doing sometimes is
responding to every single comment so I
want to let everyone know
right now that there's no beef there was
no split they didn't tell me to get lost
I didn't tell them I'm not gonna do
anything for that none of that happened
none of that happened so there's no beef
me and Ben and Brett and Jordy and all
the people over there at the Midas touch
Network
are friends
and we're friends in democracy you you
know we have Boston brine on he's a
contributor Texas Paul is on he's a
contributor uh Fred Wellman he has a
podcast with him he's on I've had
Jessica Denson on as a as a as a guest
before
um so there's there's no beef for anyone
out there listening nothing happened
nothing happened it's just we're
expanding the show and we're moving in a
direction that I think
um wouldn't wouldn't be the best for us
and the show
um under the Midas touch Banner as a
contributor while we're
broadcasting to their Facebook page
that's it simple decision no big deal
and again I worked hard and I appreciate
your guys's support on Facebook because
what what has happened over the last
week or so since we haven't been
broadcasting over there we've doubled
our views on Facebook of the show so I
thank you very much for you guys
supporting the show and coming listening
to the show even if there was some
confusion I I really didn't
there there was no beef so I didn't
think I need to make an announcement but
everyone wanted to know what the deal
was but I mean I could make up drama if
you want me to do you want me to I can
make up a big long story
I'm just kidding there's no I I wish
there was a really cool story to to tell
you about it but I don't know
[Laughter]
um a few people are chiming in here
um Sun cat says Tony I think the my
zealous brothers would like your post
your Roundtable democracy content I I
think they probably would
I think they would you're saying I
should put it on their Network I think
is what you're saying well there is
that's another uh realm of expansion
here at the Tony Michaels podcast is
with the round table of democracy
um and that's why we haven't done as
much the last few weeks because we're
we're making plans to expand that and so
those things are coming soon
I'm telling you I'm telling you things
are expanding things are going to get
bigger and the reason why is again
because of you guys the audience but our
team that we have we have such a great
team here at the Tony Michaels podcast
we have all the moderators and you know
we're looking for moderators I'll talk
about that here in a little bit and we
have great moderators we have the best
moderators in the world we have we have
Mighty librarian our local librarian
over there running the Discord being the
the director of the Discord and we got
skip over there he's a great producer
over there doing the clips and helping
moderate and helping a mighty librarian
with the Discord we got a great team
going we have MJ we have Margie we have
Deidre we have Amanda I'm missing um
Andrea on Twitch there's so many people
that are part of this team Ty like I
said earlier Ty and everyone does their
little thing that they're so good at
they're so good at these little things
and and we we patched this whole show
together to make it what it is
and I'm so proud not just of what I've
accomplished or what Gabe has
accomplished but what all of you have
done you've been your everyday engaging
staying with it
talking to each other being getting to
know each other because I was saying
this morning in the pre-show is that
that's one thing that makes me love the
audience it's sometimes like when I can
read the comments I can't tell if you're
talking to me or if you're talking to
each other because you're doing a lot of
that in the chat you're supporting each
other
in the chat this is I it has grown to be
a community a [__] em fam as it were so
don't don't be discouraged if you see
changes be excited because I'm telling
you these changes that are coming are
going to be great
and I really believe in them I believe
in what was that that Gabe Sanchez does
I actually think that piece of content
could be humongous I mean huge he could
do one of those every single day
eventually it's going to take him a
while to get there it's taken him over a
year to get where he's at now and he's
worked so hard and that piece of content
is so great
and I'm I'm so happy that you as the
audience is supporting him it is
phenomenal you should see the response
that he gets when he does his own
YouTube channel now Gabe is a little
different he gets
a little more careful
about what he says and how he edits
um so he can monetize his YouTube
channel I'm kind of the opposite I you
know me my personality is I don't give a
[__]
I don't give a [__] I'm gonna say what I
need to say when I need to say it
and that's the way it's going to be and
I believe that's the way that I should
do things is just knock over [__] as we
go
and it may not be the the best thing in
the world but right now in this moment I
believe that it is
and I appreciate you guys coming on this
journey with this this expansion so I
hope I hope that little talk there uh
puts away some of the Wonder and the
Mystery behind something that you know
wasn't real drama
and I I just didn't broadcast it I just
decided not to broadcast to their
Facebook page and maybe I should have
said something but you know I didn't
realize how many folks were still over
there watching I might as touch so if
you've joined us either on YouTube or on
Facebook or on Twitch from the mind as
such Facebook page I welcome you I'm
glad you're here Midas Mighty I am happy
that I'm happy that the sparklers are
here too Hal's guests come over and they
watch the show you're all welcome here
in the [__] em fam and as far as I'm
concerned you are members of the [__]
family
it just it just means that you gotta if
you want to watch me on Facebook you got
to go to my page so go to the Tony
michaels.com you can follow me on
Facebook there and you can watch the
show on Facebook if you so choose if you
so too so I hope that uh I hope that
puts that that thing
away and and I'm not gonna address it
again so
if you keep asking questions in the
comments it's probably because they
haven't seen this particular episode so
just steer them in the direction of
episode 476 Iowa gives Trump the middle
finger
and maybe they'll get the answer they've
been longing for of the drama that isn't
me and Midas Dutch so
I hope that helps I hope that helps
let's go to this video
um of 9 11 that I found this morning I
want to show this to you it's about four
minutes long now again it does show very
graphic parts of 9 11. and that is
um that is going to be something
that may trigger some people so I just
want to give you a fair warning here now
that some of these images might be
disturbing to you but I think on today
today's a day worth watching this close
to four minute video so here it is the
video on 9 11.
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
going on
oh my Lord
all right
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my God
remember that conversion windows
[Music]
[Applause]
Merry Christmas
everything that's going on
so there it is I know that those images
are disturbing but we cannot look away
we cannot forget what happened on that
day how it changed the world and our
thinking about the world
um those are just a few of the images as
you saw from New York City around the
Twin Towers this doesn't include footage
from the Pentagon or the wreckage in
Pennsylvania
here's the thing
is that we should
we should really remember those people
that were in those buildings around
those buildings the hero that the heroes
that went into those buildings
no matter who they voted for no matter
who they would have supported or went
and supported no matter what their
religion what their ideology
um they were Heroes that day
and to the heroes who led to the cleanup
who lost their lives after the cleanup
and those Heroes as well
there's so much good
that comes from tragedy
they're Silver Linings everywhere
but we must remember
and the reason why we must remember
these things is because we cannot lose
sight of what the future may be
terrorist
attacked us that day
terrorists
they weren't domestic they were foreign
terrorists they weren't from our country
they weren't part of our culture they
didn't like our culture they didn't like
the ideology that was happening here in
our country
they didn't like the military-industrial
complex
nor do some Americans
terrorists attacked us that day
terrorist
attacked us that day
no matter how they got through our
national security apparatus
rather is because we weren't paying
enough attention we just we were
complacent didn't think that it could
happen to us
we weren't as Vigilant as we should have
been whether it was the Bush
Administration or the Clinton
Administration before that where they
dropped the ball
on Osama bin Laden
there's so many fingers we could point
but truly it was an attack of terrorism
on our nation
period
and we must stay vigilant against
terrorism not not just not just the ones
that aren't in our country
but the Insurgency that is here now
that is painted as Patriots and
and real America
as if somehow
America became two different two
different countries all of a sudden
we we didn't become two different
countries
we aren't two different countries we
must stay vigilant against this notion
domestic terrorism is just as much or
more of a threat than the terrorism that
we got so complacent about on that day
rather the complacency was unintentional
or intentional whatever Theory you want
to spin
the key is that we stay vigilant now
and we must not go into the future
letting our guard down against
terrorists
and we must not rely on anyone to save
us
just like that day we we obviously could
not rely on the National Security
apparatus to save us from those attacks
if you go by back and you and you listen
to to the the tick tock of the minute by
minute that led to the events that you
just watched on the screen
you would know that there might have
been plenty of opportunities
plenty of opportunities to stop those
attacks
we were complacent we weren't vigilant
against terrorism
so the question is are we now
we'll learn democracies survive
an Insurgency of terrorism
and it's up to you I believe the
Battleground is information I believe
the Battleground will be fought and won
with the ballot
in our democracy will stand
it will survive
it will go on
for for us for the future Generations
your children your grandchildren
we can make it
a society that can last for many many
generations to come
we cannot we cannot
pretend
as if there is not an Insurgency of
terrorism in our country
the same sort of extremism the same sort
of terrorism that wanted to destroy our
society because they didn't like our
culture
they didn't like how advanced our
culture was
so remember this if you remember
anything on this day
just like we fought
after September 11th
for our sovereignty we must we must
fight for our democracy today
and as much as you may not believe it
you truly are you truly are
a soldier on the battlefield of
information
and we will fight this at the ballot we
will engage in our democracy
and when we do that as the pro-democracy
coalition
will become more and more clear that our
country is not divided that our country
is not in favor of trump and he's not
popularism and Trump trumpism is not
popular in this country we do not want
American fascism in our culture they
have lost the culture wars folks that's
why they're mad that's why there's an
Insurgency that's why they want to seek
Terror in our hearts
against our country against our nation
against our constitution against the
great constitutional Democratic Republic
that we have
and we should not give them a single
inch of ground
on our democracy
don't go anywhere
we'll be right back
right after this
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
foreign
to remember all the things you boycotted
can really get you stressed because
there's no good way to keep them from
becoming a cluttered mess well now
there's boycott binder the ingenious
organizer that keeps track of everything
and everyone you've ever boycotted the
72 category filing system makes it easy
to organize boycotted people places and
things so you can find them with these
the large centered area can even fit
your boycott sign but best of all when
you're done the boycott binder folds
right up so you can take it anywhere so
if you're tired of having a cluttered
mess call now and get the boycott binder
for just 29.99 plus you'll also receive
our next rep as a bonus just Loop it
around your neck to travel with ease but
call right now and we'll double the
offer that's two boycott binders and two
neck straps for just 29.99 boycott
binders brought to you by the same
makers of binders full of women
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
well the uh
the Iowa fans at the Iowa and Iowa State
game gave Trump the one finger salute
down in Florida the fourth Reich
again the neo-nazis Rhonda Santa's
supporters showed up at an overpass
to give the Nazis salute
[Music]
I'm not kidding you now what's funny
about this is that uh Elon put a tag on
this video that I that I actually
retweeted so I just embed embedded the
Tweet so you know what happens is you
can just take the the link to the video
and you can write your own tweet it
still puts the original poster of the
video down at the bottom and gives them
credit so I rarely do because it already
does that and if you don't know it well
I that can't [__] help it
Elon screwed up Twitter but here's the
thing is I'm going to show you this
video
and again
on a day like today on September 11th
when we uh remember the terrorism that
tried to bring this country to its knees
and it didn't
um we have domestic terrorists running
around trying to destroy our country
trying to terrorize us into believing
that they are going to rule our country
I don't give a [__] if you don't like me
because I'm comparing two I don't care I
don't give a [__] it is comparable
it is comparable
now is it different it is different in
that the Insurgency is here
and it is inside our country not outside
our country these are not outside forces
they are these are inside voices and
I've told you this before I think
they're going to try to steal the 2024
election just like they try to steal the
2020.
literally I think I think Republicans
are going to commit crimes right out in
the open even though they are indicted
for the same exact crimes now in Georgia
and DC
and possibly in Arizona and Michigan
they're indicted for the 16 uh fake
State electors are indicted for trying
to steal the election there they're
going to try this [__] folks
they're gonna try this nonsense it's
gonna happen
it's why we we cannot we cannot look
away
we have to realize what these things are
and what they're not and stop lying to
ourselves we cannot get [__]
ourselves
to better our country bullshitting
ourselves only makes it worse
so I understand that if that video that
I showed about 911 is triggering it
should be it should trigger emotions
inside of you God if it doesn't trigger
emotions inside of you what kind of
[__] human are you
but the same way that this video that
I'm about to show you have Rhonda Santa
supporters holding up Flags or swats
that goes on them and hailing Hitler on
an overpass in the fourth Reich of
Florida
now again
Iman that [__] Elon and Gabe
Sanchez can attest to this he is a
[__] when I say that this is
factual right Gabe Sanchez I'm not lying
is that that is checkable fact right
he's a [__] let me let me just
check the okay did you Google it did you
get it yeah you know what no lies
detected okay good good I just want to
make sure I'm not misleading The
Audience by calling Elon a [__]
just want to make sure we're on top of
it
but Elon marked this tweet here and I'll
show it to you uh it's this video of of
course the Nazis the DeSantis supporters
supporting Hitler as well I wonder what
it is about the Hitler and DeSantis that
makes them want to support both of them
I can't I probably couldn't I don't know
put my finger on it or my entire hand
you know on it but it might be something
to do with the whole fascism thing it
probably is that but I said Florida the
fourth right that's how I described this
video and you're gonna see it it is
exactly what I'm saying Florida the
fourth right there's not many there's a
lot of words you could use to describe
it but I think that's pretty appropriate
yeah now if you pan down here you can
see
now I didn't appeal this because I don't
give a [__] I don't want to go through
the process of appealing this [__] right
I just actually just send it out to a
few friends that retweeted it to get it
more traction so that people would say
that that they put a [__] warning on
this thing so this is not my video I
didn't post this video Doug whatever
this account here does Doug have a
warning I no no Doug's doesn't have a
warning
no
but mine does because I said Florida the
fourth Reich now
Yvonne's been in some trouble here
lately and I know you want to bash Elon
for a couple different things like
starlink and the ADL which I'm gonna let
you do on the show today yeah yeah
people in the uh the pre-show were like
yeah you should talk about
you should talk about the Elon today in
starlink and I was like well I kind of
like defer to Gabe Sanchez because he
loves to bash Elon so much so I'll wait
until the he's on the show and then I'll
let him you know set Elon on fire
but here's the thing is that they put a
a warning and the warning is is that
this is hate speech or whatever now
again
they kind of got in trouble for a tweet
that was sent out and they didn't you
know take it down and the ADL we kind of
got involved and then bashing the ADL
and you can explain all that but I think
what Twitter is trying to tell me is
like hey this video is anti-Semitic so
me posting it saying that they're the
fourth Reich is anti no I'm I'm trying
to point out the anti-Semitism that is
growing inside of the Insurgency of
these [__] domestic terrorists that
we call Republicans okay I'm trying to
point it out to you I'm not trying to
support it Jesus [__] Christ I mean I
wish this overpass would crumble at
beneath them to if you want to know the
God's honest truth here but you know
whatever and so if I'm anti-fascist and
I'm antifa for saying that fine whatever
[__] me I don't give a [__] but this
video is not is me posting it and
calling it Florida the fourth Reich is
not anti-semitic it is me pointing out
the anti-Semitism you [__] boneheads
I mean why why would they think now let
me let me play the audio for the folks
yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
you can uh let me turn the audio off and
we'll keep playing this here in the
background okay so you could tell how
far away this person is from this
overpass right it's pretty loud they're
pretty they're pretty far away and
there's a [__] eight Lane highway
there where people are driving and you
can still hear all the Nazis yeah I mean
I mean Hitler you know the person is on
the shoulder of the highway right they
pulled over it right cars passing by
cars passing by and you can hear they
those [__] Nazis are unified in their
chant mhm so when I see your caption
or your tweet that says you know Florida
the fourth Reich like it's I don't I
mean what am I supposed to do me the lie
right what am I what the [__] am I
supposed to do right like how am I
supposed to change this I mean I guess I
could put like a warning on it and be
like hey what you're about to see is
graphic content but it's not graphic
it's just the [__] truth about
Republicans for crying out loud and if
you don't believe if you don't believe
that the majority of these [__]
standing on this bridge have voted in
every single election if they vote for
Republican you are fooling yourself
these are the same goddamn Nazis these
are the exact same ones that went to uh
Ohio
to protest a drag show by yelling
Republican policy points into a
megaphone of people that's what they
were doing like oh you're gay you
shouldn't be here you shouldn't be able
to dress this way in public and all this
[__] all the things that Republicans
want to put in the public policy that's
not my point that's theirs
so tell the audience because having this
tweet this video tagged on my account
that it's somehow uh hate speech or
anti-semitic which it is the video in
itself these [__] people are [__]
boxes yeah
but how why why are they putting a tag
on this what happened with the ADL and
Elon Musk and then give us a little low
down on the starlink thing if you got
some links you can yeah yeah yeah so
when you sit and you're from Elon oh
this was well when you mentioned bridge
I wanted to bring up another Bridge oh
so so there's more than one Elon topic
here yeah there's more than one Elon
topic and if you want to go to that one
first then we can kind of set this down
wait we can oh oh Jesus Christ now what
okay so here's Elon Musk so if people
don't know so I used to live in San
Francisco and well easy it's SF okay no
no no you can't call it SF don't call it
San Fran or anything like that or don't
call it Frisco
come on either San Francisco or SF okay
those are the official names
is offensive yes but what happened in
San Fran yeah
oh man all right go ahead go ahead what
happened NSF well
this is the Golden Gate Bridge if people
don't know and what Elon is trying to
say goes must be great Nets what Elon is
uh talking about here are the safety
nets that were put in because people
were using the Golden Gate Bridge as a
means of committing suicide they go to
the edge and they would jump off because
this kind of goes to the whole saying
well if your friends jumped off a bridge
would you too would you do that too you
know I mean that's kind of I'm sure a
lot of trumpers and Elon Musk stands
would definitely jump off a bridge if
they were the ones who told them to do
it oh yeah they probably would that's a
good point but there's
um
there's a there's a documentary called
the bridge which is is really good it's
I mean it's sad but it's good I mean to
tell you basically these guys made a
documentary they under false pretenses
they were like oh we're going to study
the birds over on Alcatraz or
uh or an Angel Island I forget which one
and near the Golden Gate Bridge yeah so
once you pass over to Marin County there
are obviously Alcatraz Island where
people know as you know where Al Capone
was and other you know notorious
notorious Rock criminals like the movie
The Rock yeah welcome to the Rogue
welcome to the uh and then so
the the whole situation was they made
this documentary and by the end of it
you know not to spoil it but by the end
of it they got so good at recognizing
behavior and patterns that people would
have that they were able to identify who
was going to jump and who wasn't whoa
like people on the [__] Bridge are
like that person is definitely gonna
jump yeah and they actually yes and
there's a whole means of like stopping
you know preventing certain people so
because tell people because you've been
on the bridge so you can drive across it
but you can walk across it you can yeah
you can drive across it both ways and
you can walk across it and I mean the
bridge is massive I mean it is
incredible and it's structure it is I
mean I know some people that have been
to the top of the bridge
like all the way at one of the one of
the Peaks
because they were they do bridge work
and they do painting so they've been
lucky enough to be up there and shared
photos and I was like this is amazing
um but when it comes to the bridge
we implemented these nets to help
prevent people from committing suicide
so there are these nets that extend out
to stop and people and he's posting a
picture yeah and he's trying to say oh
in 1937 it costs 700 million dollars to
build this bridge in a span of four
years but in the year 2023 the cost of
having these nets is 400 million dollars
I was a fan of six years
and I mean this is apples to oranges
kind of comparison this is a
modification used put on a bridge it's
just like here in Pasadena there's a
bridge where a lot of people
would jump off the bridge and what did
they do well to prevent people as a as a
safety measure as a public safety
measure they put up a fence to make sure
that people could not jump off the
bridge
and in this very same way they're doing
they have this net out to prevent people
from committing suicide
it's not something it's like oh man
those those are pretty good Nets shut
the [__] up you [__] piece of [__]
you know what you know what's crazy
about this because I I didn't know this
story until you told me this and I I saw
it because I I'm kind of thinking like
Elon is projecting here
um and I don't I don't want to say that
he's suicidal because I don't believe
that but
um maybe what he's saying is is that he
would prefer this method If he if he had
to use it and he's really disappointed
um that they yeah I I don't know what
the hell he's saying what the hell is he
saying what the hell is the point I
don't get what the point is it's what
the [__] his point here I don't know
but again like he's also trying to
compare to be like oh well this is what
it costs in 1937. well I don't care what
it costs then I don't care what it costs
now so how many people jump off the
bridge since the since there are nets
since there are nets because I would
imagine that the Nets don't have to
catch many people because when you go to
the bridge to actually jump off of it
you're like well [__] how am I going to
jump out past those Nets right I mean
between
2000 and 2019 the bridge averaged
between 30 and 40 suicides per year
those were those were successful
suicides yes okay
and that's just an average so 30 to 40
over a 20-year span you're talking 800
people but or more you know this is
again serious that's a year
30 to 40 per year what the [__] are you
[__] kidding me that's that's dude
that's like one every couple weeks
yeah it's it's tragic that that's what
people do but they see it as an
effective now this is with the Nets
they're still there's no uh the Nets
were implemented because it was very
controversial believe me people were
like oh you're gonna ruin the [__]
the the way that we see the bridge you
can't even see the [__] Nets from
where you are even if you went up to the
point of where when you're in Marin
County The Overlook that has that first
photo that's where that that's what
people are looking is that what he's
bitching about is the look of them
he's trying I think he's bitching about
boys what about the look of people
jumping off the bridge every two weeks
what about that look huh yeah what the
[__] are you talking about man Elon you
piece of trash it really honestly it
feels like he he's sad that he doesn't
get to go jump off the bridge which to
be quite honest 400 million dollars a
year is a heavy cost to keep Elon from
not jumping off there I'm not I'm gonna
I'm gonna lie maybe he's right here
maybe he's right maybe we should give
him a take down the Nets give him a
couple months to evaluate it and then
I'm just I'm just saying this is
ridiculous it's I mean it's it's crazy
to see this uh let's see the net I
wonder where's the net Tony TB on
Discord says Pro death party strikes
again
that's what this is like oh well oh well
the look of having the Nets and the cost
isn't worth the lives that are lost what
are you talking about
yeah this is the ridiculous [__] that I
you know did you know that Republicans
are trying to Rebrand the pro-life thing
they actually there's a group of people
that went to the Senate the Republican
Senate uh Josh Hawley spoke about this I
guess there's a written uh um uh report
of his what he was said but Josh Hawley
basically said well we got to really
evaluate this pro-life thing because uh
pro-life now means now means
um you know certain certain things that
it's wasn't intended pro-choice has a
broader Spectrum again no [__]
[__] so what they want to change
their their their message to is not
pro-life anymore because they destroyed
pro-life when they made it very
blatantly obvious that they're not
pro-life they want to call it pro baby
so they want to be called pro-life
anymore they wouldn't I want to be
called Pro baby which I know maybe Elon
maybe Elon if you could toss a baby
over over the next maybe he would be
okay with that if they so the net the
net is com is to be completed in 2023
but they started yet yeah they started
Construction in 2018 and I remember when
I lived there for seven to eight years
that's this was a constant thing
people would complain I mean the same
reason that people would complain that
they didn't want any sort of public
transportation that went over the bridge
into Marin County very NIMBY why is that
why is that it's because there's a bunch
of rich people who live over the bridge
so for people who don't know so so
you're saying that the Richies didn't
want the Poors to cross the bridge on
public transit that's 100 100 that's not
even a lot [__] [__] me that's not
even like there's only one way to get
okay here look for people who don't know
there's there's one way to get over the
bridge if you're not driving or walking
and that is only by a commuter bus which
I've taken because I have friends who
live in Petaluma in Marin County so so
what so the commuter bus how awesome
it's only one way in but you have to pay
so you have to have a pass and it goes
in I don't know every few every few
hours well you have to have a pass to be
on the bus or to go across the bridge no
no you have to have a pass to go on the
bus to get over the bridge yeah gotcha
so the other thing too is like I
mentioned NIMBY which if people don't
know it's not in my backyard and that's
what that's stands for and that is very
much the the ins uh
the type of mentality that people in
Marin County have so you're like it's
not just Marine County let me tell you
something Missouri in rural Missouri
when because they want more prisons boy
they want more prisons to lock up
non-violent black men I mean that's uh
you know that's not what they say but
that's what they want
um but they want more prisons but not my
backyard put that prison over there
because I'm rich and I don't want those
prisons around me you know we we the
rich people want more prisons but we
don't want them near us you know what I
mean keep those pores and those peoples
that are like that away from me it's and
so you've got you've got people in Marin
Mill Valley uh Petaluma
um you know Sausalito uh Tiburon like
these are wealthy [__] neighborhoods
especially the ones that are right off
you got Tiburon salsa you're like the
original Rich these are the rich people
these are middle class these are like
you know celebrities live up there I
think Dana Carvey lives in Mill Valley
do you do you think if Elon actually
lived in that area do you think that's
where he would probably yeah he would
live he would live in probably like
Tiburon right or Sausalito I would guess
if I if I had to assume yeah I don't
know where I don't know where he's in
San Fran
but what I will say is so when I saw
that when I saw you off I know it is
it's believe me like as soon as I moved
there there were certain rules that were
established and that's one of them and
that was one of them so you're saying I
shouldn't just be walking up the street
and like I'm so happy I'm in San Fran
yeah please please go I mean you won't
be identified you will be identified as
a tourist and people probably you think
you think it would take me saying Sam
brand for them to know that I'm it's not
something San Francisco is a huge
transplant like magnet I mean we have
people that came from all over I come
from the Midwest people from the East
Coast right but me I'm just saying man I
worked with people who had a little
twang in their stuff so you know I guess
so all right but Elon Musk saying this
putting this out there when you
mentioned Bridges I was like [__] this
guy dude you don't understand because
what he's trying to do here is he's
trying to belittle
the prevention aspect of this this is a
suicide deterrent this is all this
[__] bro right wing [__] though like
oh well if you were a real man you
wouldn't need a net or some stupid [__]
I don't know what he's trying to say
what what was the ADL thing though oh so
the 80 so the ADL thing basically send
me send me the because there's several
tweets that he's had
[Music]
um
but [__] incredible he's like I'm not
anti-semitic but [__] the ADL basically
the the quick and dirty of that one is
as I get this as I get us something to
show you Elon Musk looked at the ADL and
was like you guys have been attacking me
since day one even because he's an
anti-semite oh yeah yeah but they were
like he goes oh but yadiel was attacking
me even before I came on and took over
uh Twitter
um and you guys are causing all of my uh
all of my advertisers to go away
here's actually a video with the with
the ADL CEO uh because they they're the
ones who are going this back and forth
basically Elon is trying to say that
he's going to sue the ADL for defamation
he's not going to do that [__] yeah he's
like deaf uh it should it shouldn't be
called the anti-death it should just be
the defamation of me or some stupid [__]
like this yeah okay and he's trying to
believe he's trying to blame him he's
trying to blame us advertising revenue
is down 60 is still down 60 primarily
due to pressure on advertisers by the
ADL that's what advertisers tell us who
[__] who man that's capitalism [__]
when you got a group out there that can
go convince [__] groups that it's not
good for them to put on your platform
because you allow anti-Semitism just to
run free on your platform how the [__]
is it the ADL CEO Jonathan greenblatt's
problem that you let Nazis run around on
your platform Elon that's not his
[__] problem just because he's
pointing it out get the [__] out of here
man and you also even if he does go in
because this is Elon writing he's like
oh I'm gonna [__] fight Mark Zucker
cage match anywhere that's not happening
oh man I'm so gonna have to I'm so gonna
buy Twitter because that's what I want
to do you only bought it because you
were forced into a buy of Delaware
yeah you got [__] sucked into it yeah
I mean he offered 54-20 420 and then
they were like okay well uh our
fiduciary responsibility is to offer
this to our uh shareholders and this is
a great deal this is way more than what
our company is currently valued at so
yeah we'll take it and it's obvious now
that it was way overpaid for it it's
obvious now 100 because you can barely
get it that's even that was before when
they had advertisers and then he cut 80
to 90 percent of the staff then
complained about issues which there are
still tons of bugs on the zap and then
on top of that now he's like oh well our
Revenue went down and advertisers left
us and we're uh blah blah blah and he's
like in the real the real problem it's
the ADL no it's just his [__]
anti-Semitism that's coming in right
well here's the um CEO he's trying to
scapegoat is what he's trying to do he's
trying to scapegoat of the
Anti-Defamation League here he is firing
back on MSNBC in an interview it's
interesting this happening while we have
these sentences being handed down in
January 6 but the reality is Q Anon
enthusiasts conspiracy theorists
hardened anti-semites all of these types
of people who are under rocks before are
now out in the open and so again when
you have Nazis chanting ban the ADL when
you have swattings of synagogues when
you have bomb threats against Jewish
institutions and the Jewish holidays of
Rosh Hashanah are just a few weeks away
that's why oh man it's it feels like it
feels like to me that
um we've been putting out the same you
know calls for this over the last two
years as we as I've called the
Republicans the Nazi party because they
aren't but look at this look at these
two I'm not look dude Tony I'm not great
at okay magamath is very hard for me
right
okay so if numbers go up is that bad or
is that good it's probably not a good
thing in this situation when you're
talking about when you're talking about
uh anti-semitic incidents
um it's probably not a good thing oh
okay so this is like never goes I'm
against Jewish people right and you know
what I love Elon Musk saying oh yeah
well show me one proof one little piece
of evidence that shows there's
anti-Semitism on the app okay uh that's
pretty easy dude we could literally
search it and we know that you're gonna
suppress it or one one just one example
what the [__] one example we can find we
can find one example easily right well
let's finish this interview here what's
this uh other what's is this one of his
examples is this is his tweet thread
where he started bitching and moaning
okay well let's finish this video then
we'll go to his tweet thread and I bet
there's anti-Semitism right there in
that tweet thread but let's let's watch
the community is on edge and that's why
ADL will not shrink we will not hesitate
we will be ferocious and fighting hate
and the empty threats and privileged
lawsuits they don't scare us and you
know like you said Elon Musk truly is
the wealthiest man in the world he's one
of the most brilliant innovators of our
time he controls the most powerful media
platforms on the planet that's not true
so blaming the okay I'm going to clarify
something no he's about to say the
scapegoating part okay well I'll get to
that I just want to back it up a bit and
the reason why I want to back it up a
bit is because of this is Elon is not
the richest man in the world
um he's not close to it we know that he
would have been able to just pay for
Twitter he wouldn't have to go sell it
sold to the Devil with the Saudis he
does not control Twitter Saudis to some
degree control Elon and Twitter and he's
definitely he's definitely not one of
the most Innovative minds of our time he
takes credit for the most Innovative
minds of our time but I just want to be
clear on that right and that's that is a
good point The Innovation that comes
from the companies that he owns comes
from the people that are working there
the engineers the physicists the [__]
after the the the rocket scientists
right these are the people who are
making the Innovations possible
well if Elon is the one who's like oh
man I built this [__] geometric car
isn't it cool well here's the thing if
you believe that the guy who talks to
cat turds on a daily basis is an
Innovative genius I'm pretty sure
catterra doesn't like him anymore not
really well you know that happens uh
when you uh because he's like I'm being
suppressed and it's like dude you have
an account that's being
propped up right well uh get in the
kitty litter there can't turd and you'll
discover why you're a [__] idiot okay
let's let's listen to the uh scapegoat
part we're just a small non-profit so
blaming the Jews if you will that's
classic scapegoating it's not what
happened here but we won't stop you know
fighting all forms of hate because
that's what we do it's certainly given
some cover as you say these people come
out of the Shadows again and speaking
more loudly and we've seen violence
because
I just showed you a video of the fourth
Reich in Florida yeah and and Elon
flagged me for that which is kind of
[__] crazy
um but that's that is the the insane
thing about this you would you would
think that Elon would be smarter or have
a little bit more guidance on um
better guidance on this if you're gonna
go about suing the
Anti-Defamation League
then you better expect the fact that
they're going to prove or
fight the defamation claim that you're
making right the group is literally
called that specialized you're right and
has the word that you want to come after
them for in the [__] name dude okay
the idea that Elon Musk oh I'm gonna sue
the deaf the Anti-Defamation League for
defamation isn't that funny you're not
going to sue them because what would
happen is they say okay great you want
to do it bet show me everything it's
Discovery Time open up the [__] thing
right we're gonna we're gonna have
access to these tweets
we're gonna have access to the messages
we're going to have access to other
Communications and we're going to prove
that anti-Semitism does exist on this
platform you have done very little to
stop it you have removed certain groups
that were in charge of
of not censoring but monitoring that
activity to remove it because it's
because well because I went through this
yesterday on the um
the patreon Sunday rant because I had it
open to the public yesterday and a lot
of it was self-promotion in that we were
trying to tell people what the schedule
was going to be this week because it's
going to change we're expanding here
yeah and tomorrow the real change
happening yeah you had your pre-show
yeah it was great it went great the
conversations were great and I I was
happy that people joined us to talk
about those things and we actually
talked a little bit about Elon Musk and
again that's where I defer to you but
yesterday people were like oh so your
chat because I was talking about trolls
and getting rid of trolls and they're
like oh so your your chat's not about
freedom of speech I'm like no no it's my
[__] chat I don't have to let you say
your Nazi ass hateful [__] in my chat I
don't have to protect your speech in my
chat that's ridiculous go out on a
sidewalk and hold a sign that says you
think I that Tony Michaels is a [__]
idiot that's your right to protest me go
do that
you do not have the right to protest me
in my [__] chat that I control this
is the same thing as you can't if you
hate Walmart you can't go to Walmart and
spray paint on the side of their
building [__] Walmart that's not
something you can do that's a that's
against the [__] law they'll charge
you
um for damage property you [__]
bonehead but you can stand out on the
public sidewalk in front of Walmart not
on their private sidewalk but on the
public side and you can hold up a sign
that says [__] Walmart you can do that
that's your freedom that's the [__]
craziest thing that I've ever seen about
these right Wingers is they really truly
don't get the freedom of speech and
that's what Elon when he says when he
says I want freedom of speech he means
his yeah speech which it's his platform
so technically it's his speech so he
allows the speech of hate of Nazis of
anti-semites because he [__] is one
[__] Dirtbag here he is he says Elon
this [__] says to be clear our
platform's name on the manner of
anti-Semitism it looks like we have no
choice but to file deformation lawsuit
against the Anti-Defamation League oh
the irony oh yeah oh the irony Elon let
me tell you there are two there are two
outcomes and one of them is the most
likely scenario one is
he does sue them for defamation
and in either the case gets thrown out
or he [__] steps in a huge pile of
[__] and he can't get out of it and he
gets proven wrong
the second is I think the more likely
scenario he's not going to do anything
he's not going to do a single thing
because what happens is if he does this
that is more
because here look for a guy that is
hemorrhaging
hemorrhaging money at Twitter wait I
thought he was the richest man in the
world the richest man in the world I
surely could plug that hole I'm just
right saying man look or can he not find
a hole even it had hair around it what
what is it just like the fake ramaswamy
wouldn't know the truth if it hit him in
the face or sat on his face come on man
we're trying to get to zero days right
right right
Elon Musk wouldn't know oh [__] what to
do here if it was
shown to him right before his face right
before his very eyes and this scenario
Elon was like oh man I guess we're gonna
have to sue the ADL for defamation oh
the irony well here's the problem Elon
your company is hemorrhaging money
you've lost 80 which he then later
reveals in this [__] thread eighty
percent or or 60 to 80 percent of the
revenue has still not returned but it's
all because the ADL it's all because the
Jewish people got a scapegoat like way
back when when the the wells were
poisoned I don't know if people know
that story but that's where scapegoating
comes from by the way it's blaming the
Jews for poisoning the well
that's scapegoating that's what Elon is
doing and that's why he's blaming the
ADL for trying to take away his Revenue
when really it's actually elon's fault
yeah
pointing out what's happening on the
platform to the advertisers and they're
going oh yeah you're right that's
probably not a good idea because the
advertisers don't know unless it's
pointing out to him maybe so so [__]
so [__] sue the advertisers I hope I
hope he sues the ADL and every other
Advertiser and they come back to him and
say well we have the right to do
whatever we want we were in a contract
and we pulled out and we didn't we
didn't want to continue work with you we
decided that actually the ADL was right
and they showed us all the evidence and
we actually had a little bit of a shift
in our perspective because we didn't
want to associate our company our brand
our image of reputation because again
that's a big part of companies and and
what they stand for is like what is the
public perception what is our brand
recognition going to be
over a makeup company that's also
supportive of a platform that is
anti-Semitic I don't know if you should
though who knows they might be more
successful because we know Republicans
love to put on makeup like Ron DeSantis
well that is true and his and Donald
Trump yeah Donald Trump which I I hope
we can get to the Iowa Iowa State game
here by the end let's go to the Elon
story about uh because I think this
one's significant as well a lot of Elon
stories are not significant because he's
just such a [__] box but this one here
is significant where he is taken down
starlink at a crucial moment for Ukraine
to access it
um it seems like he's doing Putin's
bidding here what do you think you know
if I was a betting man I would say yep
that's completely correct because what
we have here is we have Elon Musk who by
the way oh I didn't how did I get myself
in this war you put yourself in it you
put yourself in it you were the one
who came in and and offered your product
he wanted he wanted to look like a hero
let's be free yeah yeah he didn't give a
[__] about that and then later he works
he just wanted to look like if I
remember correctly when that happened he
was like oh uh well the government isn't
paying I'm not making any money on this
uh and then he tried to up the charge to
the federal government
but we have to remember because I've
seen this response by a ton of people
online and I made account I was like oh
you know I [__] Nick sorter the guy
who's in Maui right now that people
locals don't like but is being called
out by other people and then talk about
it talk about Putin's puppet holy [__]
Nick that guy it was like oh look at
these people you've got Oprah and you've
got the rock who are asking for any for
donations when they're millionaires or
billionaires look I'll say this I agree
that they should be putting their money
where their mouth is if they're gonna
ask for donations they should double it
or match it or something
the other part of this is he goes oh
well then you look at Elon Musk a really
good billionaire
who's giving starlink access to people
he didn't give [__] he's charging DOD
for it yeah so the original he
originally he moved the goal post on
this because he's like I'm gonna provide
it for free and then he's like but I
want money now yeah because I'm broke
really I'm not actually the richest man
in the world so I want I want DOD to pay
for it yeah get the [__] out of here man
so we need the American people are
paying Elon Musk to use this system in
Ukraine so Ukraine can fight this war
against a [__] murderous dictator
Vladimir Putin who it seems to be it
seems to be is in bed with the Saudis
with the Saudis uh control Elon so it
see I don't know it just you know it's
kind of like you got the [__] wall
with all the string on it I ain't to be
a conspiracy dearest here but God damn
but yeah that's really what it is you
you've got you've got Elon Musk who is
now complaining
and that well actually it was
complaining and now has been revealed
that at a crucial point
when the Ukrainian military could have
made an attack
Elon Musk was like oop off right right
and
and people are like oh well and these
are the comments that I got because I
made a tweet about this and I had
comments one person I was like you
[__] idiot you're so [__] dumb you
don't even realize what you're [__]
arguing right now this guy said it's not
Elon musk's job
to keep it on or keep it off he
shouldn't this is not a fair criticism
it is when you come into an agreement
and say you're going to offer your
services and your product especially at
a DOD payment schedule to a country that
is being invaded
by a goddamn war criminal AKA Vladimir
Putin
when you have someone that is offering
services and products and then so again
opt-in they opted in he didn't have to
agree to it the government couldn't
didn't have to force them into it or
anything he was like oh yeah I'll do it
I'll put in there I'll be I'll be the
war hero
as soon as that happens you accept full
responsibility and criticism if your
company now
decides chooses willingly makes the
decision to turn off access to starlink
and leave a country that is trying to
defend itself from an invasion by a war
criminal
like you can't you can't argue that and
you can't say oh that's not that's not a
fair criticism it is he came in he I
mean I could criticize I can be cynical
I know if I want to be this this is a
free country with freedom of speech mind
you but yeah
and that platform I has what I can say
whatever I want against Elon to be frank
it's freedom of speech it's my freedom I
gotta move on to some other stories I
wanna I'm gonna impend on this point but
we got to move on to some other stories
and the reason why is I want to get to
the the Trump Iowa rather he was booed
or not how the right wing changed the
audio that's fantastic dude I'm not even
jacket jacket jacket you know what I'm
uh any any people who are on the on the
left I'm just gonna call it out right
now I have a tweet and I want to call
this out and I want to call attention
this goddamn
idiot okay good idiot so let's let's and
this person's and you people like you
only attack people on the right well
look I'm gonna criticize someone on the
left for me let's do that I love that
but before we go to that there's a
grooming question in the chat which is a
huge story I think is going to become a
huge story especially as we make changes
here
um on the [__] fam Universe
um Margie asked is Gabe growing a
mustache
I just want to make sure if you're gonna
have the mustache for the uh live or not
well maybe in November I'll grow a
mustache okay good we'll see we'll see
we'll see well this is this is a good
spot here to tell the yard it's just the
lighting I didn't shave yesterday so
this is what it is why we've got the
audience here tomorrow will be the very
first what was that live after the
Johnny Michaels podcast what'll happen
is you'll watch the show here tomorrow
I've got Greg o'lear on as a guest and
then we're gonna have Texas Pawn Gabe
will probably join us at some point
before his show and then right after our
show on YouTube and twitch you'll go
directly to what was that line with
Gabe's inches so don't forget to go to
the Tony michaels.com scroll down find
Gabe's links go follow those things and
tomorrow you'll automatically be shot
into his show and it'll be a three hour
long me and Gabe tomorrow so to be Tony
Mike's podcast and then what was that
live it was just a great I just thought
it was a good comment good question
you're talking about someone asked if
it's November 2023 or November 2024 uh
uh who knows we'll see okay well we'll
go who knows maybe I'll grow I'll grow a
mustache leading up to the election it
could be it could you know all right
well uh Margie thanks for the question
the controversial question and then
um so this is what is this the Lefty
that you want to attack yeah yeah yeah
okay great great everybody attack let's
I just want to call them out for what
happened all right so this is full
context
I made a tweet and you can play the
video this is the video that rsbn posted
okay and this is the one that was going
around the internet that the right was
changing the audio right yeah yeah this
is actually
a video this is the real video This is
the real video this is the video
see if the audience can hear booze here
as uh uh the Cheeto dust q and honor
Grandpa Poopypants makes his way out too
which especially comes more prevalent at
the end of the video but yeah but listen
[Applause]
please
here come the booze
[Applause]
so what happens is what happens is he
goes out and it takes a while for
everyone to realize yeah that he's there
because it is a stadium I don't know if
you've ever been in a stadium but it's
hard to see sound you know right yeah
well and sometimes you see people like
interacting some way but you can't
really see what they're doing yeah and
it takes a while for the stadium to
realize that that they should Boo this
person right because he's not it's not
like he's on camera at all or anything
like that it's people it's this
and then like it's just like a domino
effect where everyone's like what are
they talking about what are they talking
about Trump Trump trump Trump's hearing
this
right so they boo him they often want to
give him and I mean some of them are
yays and hip arrays and all that kind of
[__] but there was an audible boo he's
not as popular as he wants to make us
think he is and this is rsbn's yeah they
post and they still have it up they
still have it up it's still there now
you said this was your uh quote tweet of
rsbn you said rsbn sharing a video of
trump getting booed is perfection now
who you're talking about here is Ramblin
duck 303 go Blue
and he said I don't think you know what
booing is but there was clear booing in
the video I mean there's clear cheering
I mean there there was cheering there
was booing as well yeah and you know to
be fair you know that and you said weird
didn't oh so this is what happened so
basically the Tweet got deleted I didn't
delete it but um something must I'm
talking about this though this tweet no
no go down go down I had a tweet that
said uh what the original tweet said
might help if you listen to it with
sound I'll leave the rest to you LOL
so that's we got deleted I guess by
mistake or by accident I have no idea
there's no reason why I would delete
that tweet so this person responds
and they say uh nope uh go to show
replies because it looks like I didn't
respond to that one
no no no no no no no go no sure no oh my
god do I gotta take over just go back go
back
um
go forward oh just go forward what are
you doing dude okay hang on where where
are you wanting where which which
here let me get the tweet for you here
here it is you gotta show more replies
there's the show replies no okay here
you go this is the one
okay here it is click that link
all right here's here's all right I'm
[__] it up here so anyway so this is
it this person screenshot it better you
deleted that crap Gaslight boy
so it said that it it showed that my
tweet was deleted which I was like oh
that's weird I didn't delete the Tweet
anyway
so like I said might help if you listen
to the whole video or my lesson if you
help with the sound I'll leave the rest
to you LOL which is exactly what I said
before that then they said dude as if I
didn't have the audio on it's noise with
plenty of cheers and your headline is
[__] and misleading might help if
you post assuming some of us will
actually view with sound
so they were like oh you deleted your
Tweet why do you [__] guess like wait
I'm like I don't know what happened I
didn't mean to delete it but hey it got
deleted so here I'm gonna double down
and I'll say this weird didn't mean to
delete it but I'll say it again
would it might help if you listen to it
with sound I'll leave the rest to you
you seem to be a capable functioning
human adult I don't know can you find me
uh maybe they only listen to the first
three seconds before they started booing
can you can you find me the the two
audios one that's the the right wing
list putting out because they were
changing the audio of this video to try
to convince people that no he wasn't
actually being mood because they had to
change yet find out see if you can find
that one but I want to show everyone uh
because that well I was gonna say
there's one more part to it
which what the the feud here yeah go
back oh okay God damn it what do you
keep doing dude what's what's the what's
the what's the feud what's it's when
funny how the narrative changes uh-huh
the video you posted so this is what
this person responded with after I was
like weird I didn't delete it but I'll
say it again because I don't know why
this would be controversial it is true
there was booing in the video and didn't
seem like you listened to it would sound
so this person funny how the narrative
changes the video you posted provided no
booing others called it mixed reaction
later in the day because they're not
silly little influencers assuming people
like it without paying attention sorry
Gabe I bothered to listen and called you
out I mean it clearly has booing in it I
mean whether you like it or not here's
the funny thing this rambling dick I
mean Ramblin duck 303 uh says they said
that and I was like oh that's weird if
I'm a silly little influencer why are
you following me also here is the
[__] article from mediaite which is
not left-leaning it's if anything center
right
they're so dumb these [__] well they
did they rained booze down on him again
when they realized Trump was in the
stadium they stopped cheering and
started Brewing if you listen to the
whole video
especially in the second half you're
like oh yeah there was booing it's all
right I'm looking for the other video
too well here's here's uh and now I I
use this as the thumbnail today
this is an image going around the
internet here you can see Donald Trump
waving through the private [__] box
that he had that was one difference
between uh Trump and DeSantis is
DeSantis try to sit with the crowd and
they were flipping him off too but Trump
decided he would hide in a box right in
a private box and he came he came to the
window like a hostage or or an inmate
maybe rather and he and maybe he's
practicing I don't know and he was
waving through the glass and everyone
was flipping him off now you see this
picture here where they're flipping him
off and everyone keeps saying that these
people are flipping the people off on
the balcony and clearly they are not
they are flipping him off who is
standing here it's [__] crazy but you
know what do you know many people are
saying that the photo of Donald Trump
his mug shot is not actually the photo
of the year the photo of the year is
this man giving [__] well it could be
some are claiming that this is faked and
I'm like what the [__] are you talking
about they're like no look at the
Shadows on his fingers and all this [__]
I'm like but the guy's over here too
right I mean what they're saying is is
they posted this guy
closer to the trump in this perspective
do they know how photos work well I
don't know if they know how like
perspective works I don't think they
understand how that how that kind of
works they're like Trump is too big
because look how far away he is from
this one I'm like yeah but the guy is
closer anyways you know what he's
supposed to do with these people I don't
know it's [__] idiots man idiots on
the right idiots on the left I'll tell
you well let me show you an idiot let me
show you an idiot some some wild stuff
this video is what I don't know what the
[__] he's saying here one number two I
don't know why they're playing the music
and he's acting like he's speaking or
something
it's just the end of his rally well this
is he's a [__] ominous song at the
end he's like all you Patriots out there
right I just love you all so much and I
know that if you go to jail for me I
won't help you at all right well this
one's even crazier than that because
he's talking about electric tanks and
[__] it's it's some wild stuff take it
take a listen
and now we are a nation that wants to
make our great army tanks all electric
what I mean I mean I'm not gonna say
that we shouldn't make them electric and
I'm sure people are talk this is the
same stupid [__] when the the American
alcohol association's like you know what
people should probably only consume two
beers a week that's probably actually
none but two is like the max that you
should brought I'm gonna consume a lot
more but that's their recommendation
like the government like no it's not the
government it's an association that
studies on this stuff yeah who is Joe
Biden is a forcing two beers in that
thing no so just because people are
printing in magazines
surmising or or are longing for a day
that there's electric tanks doesn't mean
that's what we're doing you [__] fool
but let's keep going I really I really
like is here's the thing somebody in the
back is holding a Trump no one like
Christy know him little little uh little
signs which means that more than one was
printed which means that I don't know
who at who at this rally is trying to
push this idea but since they're in
South Dakota
she she endorsed she's like I endorsed
president Trump care like he's like I
endorsed him first oh really damn dude
damn who's sleeping with who here okay
let's okay let's finish because it gets
much better here I'm I'm gonna be honest
it gets way better so
that they will not be able to go very
far either
few pollutants will be released into the
air as we blast our way through [__]
string what what is it what he's like
although they will not be able to last
as long the charge as as if tanks don't
run out of fuel what the [__] is he
talking about I have no idea what the
[__] is he doing they'll run at it
they'll run out of electricity the
batteries oh my God excuse me excuse me
very rude electric tanks very rude sit
down sit down tanks electric tanks
please don't even enter The Warfield let
me get those diesel diesel tanks
I don't know the best oh it gets way
better it gets way better with polluting
because here's the thing what are you
talking about we definitely want to
pollute our enemies battles how many
balloons too many I know the best kinds
of pollutants he seriously says we want
to pollute our atmosphere because it's
the enemy's Atmos I don't know let's
listen
[Music]
what is the music yeah I don't know we
are a nation who wants to make our
jet fighters
with a green energy stamp
losing 15 percent efficiency but
allowing us to keep our enemies
atmosphere clean up the lupus while we
attempt to knock out their planes all
over the skies
their atmosphere what the [__] is he
does he think that National National
borders go all the way up and it's like
a bubble all the way up into this man he
thinks the same thing like uh like
Margaret Taylor green and the same thing
like Herschel Walker where he's like oh
those other countries got those bad air
and they want to bring that bad air over
here as as if we don't share in uh
what's it called an atmosphere we're on
the same goddamn Planet you [__] Flat
Earth [__] what the [__] is he
talking about
that the enemy's atmosphere that's our
[__] atmosphere you dumb [__] what
the [__] is he talking about Tony you
don't get it I guess I just don't
[__] get don't science and facts what
the [__] is he talking so he's like he's
like you know what we should do we
should not only when we go over to kill
people with rockets and bombs we should
just be polluting the atmosphere because
it's only their atmosphere the [__] is
he talking I mean he's like you gotta
it's gonna be it's gonna be the best you
don't you don't understand okay we're
gonna have the best fighter plans you
know what we're gonna do instead we're
just gonna drop gasoline from the sky
because what is it what is he's like oh
yeah yeah we're gonna make we're gonna
make jet fighter pilots just eject with
a bunch of trash out of their planes
it's gonna be amazing people say oh
don't bomb a country but what about a
garbage
so [__] dumb what the hell is he
talking about no idea I mean I don't get
music the violin that's that's the other
thing too that gets the violin in the
background where he's like ominous like
there and he's like
this is terrible this is not the worst
my gathers gonna be
gonna be I'm talking about number one if
we can make electric tanks that's pretty
[__] cool if you want to know the
honest truth that's pretty [__] cool
if we can make electric tanks not
because of the atmosphere but which
which by the way remember that the same
people who are supporting Donald Trump
also support Elon Musk were like yeah
hey hey hey hey easy look at this cyber
truck easy you're gonna you're gonna
confuse them you're gonna you're gonna I
can't you're gonna get them confused
help them
changing their pronouns from Kiss My Ass
to I don't know whose I am if you're not
careful Gabe okay okay I'm just saying
I'm just saying if if they're supporting
if they're supporting Elon Musk in the
in the electric vehicles that he creates
especially this new Cyber truck that has
continued to fail all of these tests and
they're like oh man check out the Cyber
truck it's on the back of this trailer
oh boy it's like yeah it also had a
difficulty of going six inches on a curb
it had to have a ramp if you're gonna
tell me this is the the future yeah well
correct if this pickup truck is going to
be the future and not somebody somebody
buying a Ford F-150 you're [__] crazy
you're crazy do you remember the Pontiac
Aztec oh yeah yeah I remember yeah
those things were I remember the Pontiac
Aztec was the gift that was given to the
remaining winners of season one survivor
really I remember when they got when
they landed on the airport yeah they
couldn't even sell and they were giving
them away they were like here's here's
some money and then five of them [__] we
got plenty of these [__] they
got they got the like uh the the glossy
Santan kind of color for the Aztec and
they're like and now Fresh Off The Fleet
the Pontiac Aztec you guys just got
yourself a brand new car and they're
like cool especially the one dude
whose tactic was to walk he was an old
dude who walked around naked I don't
know if people I've only watched one
season it was the first season and it
was the [__] Pontiac Aztec was one of
the prizes that they had oh and by the
way
it was also the car that was using
Breaking Bad that's right right okay so
so let's so here's the thing
if you imagine a Pontiac Aztec which is
a very unsuccessful successful car in
the car market in America very it was
[__] it it [__] the bed almost
immediately I believe this is the guy
they're talking about the guy that I was
like oh he walked around naked all the
time Richard Hench Richard Hatch okay so
so the Aztec the pawning again you go
Google what it looks like and if you
take another really just horrible
[__] car that that tanked on the on
the American Market which is the dolor
pun intended no pun intended yeah well
it could be
um but if you take you take the DeLorean
and the Aztec and if they could [__] and
have a baby that would be elon's stupid
cyber truck so it took two cars that
were just dog [__] like maybe cat turds
almost yeah yeah I want to say it that
way and he took those and he's like you
know what both of these designs and
marketability was horrible let me make
those into a truck and see if it works
and it didn't I mean if people remember
if people remember when they were doing
the presentation for the Cyber truck on
stage he was like and the windows are
indestructible and then they threw this
weighted ball at the window and it
cracked and like oh I guess he got to do
some more testing but also people need
to understand
there are physics involved with car uh
impact and you want to have some give to
a car
and they're like oh no you could smash
this car and then nothing will happen to
it well you might want to consider the
object inside the [__] metal frame
there's a reason why you would
structure a car to have some give also
protecting the people inside but have
some give which by the way I watched a
video the other day speaking of crashes
I watched a video the other day that was
doing a bunch of like crash tests these
simulations of other cars the new Ford
Bronco holy [__] man nobody should buy
that car one no one no one should buy
that you're breaking my heart as much as
I was like oh I would love a Ford Bronco
especially a new one do not do it if
people look up if you just Google this
look up the crash test simulations for
all the new like trucks and stuff
horrible horrible dude the thing is
smash like a pancake it's nuts do you
know do you know harkening back to Trump
not knowing what the hell he's talking
about and saying [__] to ominous music
and really like yeah this is gonna be
good because people are definitely going
to be tricked by this today's 9 11
September 11th yeah okay and we remember
what happened in 2001 we shouldn't
um forget what happened Sergeant Joker
here posted something a tweet here that
I think is um is crazy maybe Trump when
he's talking about his um with his music
and
he's trying to talk to his supporters
about how they're trying to banned
ceiling fans and beer and they're making
beer gay and tanks electric and he's
woken wokenizing everything I want you
to remember these two images side by
side and I want you to never forget this
uh on on any September 11th but any day
how these two things are not the same
but they're not that far apart and
that's what I want you to remember about
Trump and trumpism and Maga and his
supporters as we watch all these
insurrectionists go to jail and federal
prison for terrorism
the same way that the Terrace fully
planes into the buildings to try to
destroy our way of life in our culture
and our society here is the same way the
Maga terrorist the domestic terrorist
went to the capital to try to take away
our society our culture our Constitution
and our way of life these take these two
things seem so similar I just should do
the show on such a
dire point but here's a good point
tomorrow you're going to get three hours
three [__] hours
three hours two hours a day Tony
Michaels podcast we're gonna have Greg
o'lear at the bottom of the hour Texas
Paul join us Gabe will join us near the
end of the show and then when the show
ends here on YouTube and twitch you will
get directed to Gabe Sanchez's YouTube
channel and his twitch Channel where you
should subscribe and you should watch
his brand new show on Tuesdays
Wednesdays and Thursdays directly after
this show called what was that live with
Gabe the guy with the last name Sanchez
so don't forget tomorrow our schedule is
going to be the same here on the Tony
Michaels podcast but you're going to
want to stick around for the third hour
of the [__] fam universe and catch
what was that live the very first what
was that live with the guy with the last
name
Sanchez
so subscribe here at the Tony Michaels
podcast go to the Tony michaels.com
that's the Tony michaels.com scroll down
and subscribe to Gabe Sanchez's YouTube
channel if you click on if you click on
his merch tab that'll take you to his
link tree which where all that stuff
will be yeah go to the merch tab click
on Gabe's merch tab it'll go to those
link tree you can find all that stuff
there if you want a pardon blanket we
were showing that before go get you a
pardon blanket and merge store follow
him everywhere you're not going to want
to miss what was that line tomorrow the
very I just wanna I just want to address
there seems to be some rumor in the chat
here I'm going to be doing the show in
the nude with a monster bet you're
goddamn ass I am so in the nude in the
nude with a mustache is it a mustache if
you're is it nude if you're wearing a
mustache though is it nude
we'll figure that out tomorrow on the
show that's great but also people people
on Twitch
uh make sure to follow me on Twitch
because it'll go for people who watch on
Twitch it'll go also on my channel as
well over there that's right that's
right so YouTube and twitch again you
can go to thetonymichaels.com or you can
go to
iamgabesanchez.com and you'll be able to
find those links there so go to the Tony
michaels.com you click on Gabe's merch
store or you can just go to I am Gabe
sanchez.com you'll find all the links
there follow him uh be excited for I'm
excited about tomorrow I'm excited this
is crazy this is like the first day of
school man yeah I know well I mean we
practice it the last few weeks like on
patreon and it's worked but I'm excited
about tomorrow about um more than
anything just coming and raiding your
show I I wanna I'm gonna come on and
there you go so make sure you make sure
you send me the join link because I'm
gonna that's fine I'll pop in for just a
minute I want to be on the very first
one yeah yeah no hey I get it I get it
we'll let you on the show great same
time same place tomorrow don't forget
don't forget get third hour with what
was that line with Gabe Sanchez see you
tomorrow serves up [__]
you've been listening to the Tony
Michaels podcast in your face commentary
of current events and political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] em
[Music]
Murphy's mealborn headass Beacon